-Well, it's 2022,
and believe it or not,
all of our problems are solved,
the pandemic is over
and our democracy is saved.
Wait, I'm sorry. Hold on.
That doesn't sound right.
-See, I told you.
Seth, I bet Bryan 100 bucks
that you read anything
I put in the cards.
Pay up, Bry.
-Damn it, Wally.
If you ever pull anything
like that again,
I'll give you a raise
and buy you a car!
What?
-Hoo-ho!
Yes!
I did it again.
-Can I just have
the real cards now, Wally?!
[ Clears throat ]
[ Laughter ]
COVID is more widespread
than ever,
and our democracy
is on the brink.
Yes, that is more like it.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
One of the biggest mistakes
we as human beings make
is thinking next year
will be better than last year,
even though the best indicator
of how things are going to go
is how they've been going.
It's not like Father Time
pulls Baby New Year aside
and says,
"Go easy on him, kid,
because I was a real ass ache.
Remember when 2020 ended
and we all thought
we were in the clear,
only to make it six days
until the Capitol storm?
And if you thought
that was crazy,
we only made it two days
into 2022
before the worst thing
at a Jets game
was somehow
not Jets related.
[ Laughter ]
And I have to say this year's
New Year celebrations
did not inspire a lot
of confidence that 2022
is going to be
a much more cheerful year.
For example,
at one point they played
John Lennon's "Imagine"
per tradition
while a smaller-than-usual
crowd danced in giant
hats branded with the Planet
Fitness logo.
-♪ Imagine no possessions ♪
-Now, in fairness
to those people,
the Beatles were wearing
those same hats
in the "Get Back" documentary.
Who can forget
that incredible moment
when John turned to Paul
and said,
"Hey, Paul, wouldn't it be great
if there was peace on Earth
and a gym
with no enrollment fees?"
"Well, that would be Super,
John."
"And what are they gave you
the first month free?"
"Oh, now you're giving me
the giggly wigglys, John.
[ Siren blaring ]
Whoa, you know
what that siren means.
New impression alert.
I spent the holiday break
at a special two-week
impression camp seminar
where we learned how to do
what's called a two-hander,
where you impersonate
two people at once.
It's like they say
at Impression camp,
"Do you want to be
life of the party
or would you rather go
to impression camp?"
[ Laughter ]
Point is, I didn't know
him personally,
but I'm fairly confident
that is not what
John Lennon wanted us to imagine
when he wrote the song.
Otherwise, the lyrics would
have been a little different.
♪ Imagine there's a planet ♪
♪ Where you can exercise ♪
♪ Everybody's into fitness ♪
♪ They're are beefy guys ♪
[ Laughter ]
I feel like by doing that,
it's like a favor to Gal Gadot.
And by the way, if that
bizarre scene didn't give you
a sense of how we're entering
2022,
then how about this drunken rant
from CNN New Year's Eve co-host
Andy Cohen, who absolutely
went off on former Mayor
Bill de Blasio
after the ball dropped?
I don't know what
Andy's specific complaint is,
but it doesn't matter
because this is pretty much
how New Yorkers
talk about every mayor,
regardless of who they are
or what they do.
-Let me tell you something.
-Please tell us something, Andy.
-Watching Mayor de Blasio...
-Don't go on a rant.
-...do his "victory"
lap dance after four years...
-Don't -- don't do it.
-...of the crappiest term
as the mayor of New York.
-That's how you want
to start the new year?
-The only thing the Democrats
and Republicans can agree on
is what a horrible mayor
he has been.
So sayonara, sucka.
2022, It's a new year.
Because guess what?
I have a feeling of
I'm going to be standing
right here next year.
And you know
I'm not going to be looking at
dancing as the city
comes apart.
...you!
-I mean, I think he's been
spending too much time
with those "Real Housewives."
Even Jennifer would be like
you should have a club soda.
I mean, look at him.
Anderson Cooper is holding
him back by the jacket
the way you hold back
your friend
who is over served at SantaCon.
Look, forget it, Chase.
Let's just go harass
some outdoor diners.
Given the choice
between those two,
I just want you to know you want
Andy to be the belligerent one.
Because when Anderson Cooper
wants to fight you,
you're already dead.
[ Laughter ]
And as for the rant itself,
agree or disagree,
but if you've ever been
on the F train
or in a bar at 3:00 A.M.,
you've probably heard
that exact thing, word for word.
It's nothing personal.
It's just a bargain
you make as mayor of this city.
In return for getting
to live in a mansion,
you serve as a sponge
for everyone's rage.
It's the only way we can live
together in this city.
We have to have a common enemy
in the form of the mayor,
whoever they are.
Otherwise, we turn on each other
in the streets
and you'd see Spider-Man
and Buzz Lightyear
just wailing on each other
in Times Square while a cabbie
runs over the Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree.
The same was true
for Bloomberg and Rudy.
It'll be true for
Eric Adams as well.
Angry rants against the mayor
is such a standard part
of New York life
they've been incorporated
into the subway announcements.
-Stand clear of the
closing doors, please.
And remember freaking de Blasio
can kiss my ass.
Oh.
Next stop, 42nd Street.
-Yeah.
So that kind of gives you
a good sense
of the state of things
as we enter 2022.
That's not to say there
aren't reasons for optimism,
or at least reasons for us
all to be motivated to work
together toward a better future.
We can't give in
to the fatalism,
and we have to keep pushing
forward together in solidarity
for a more just
and brighter world.
But along the way,
we're going to do some shots
and they're going to be times
where we need Anderson Cooper
to hold us back.
So just, you know,
where your puffiest coat
because it's easier for him
to get a grip on it.
For example, that Andy Cohen
New Year's Energy
is pretty much how I felt
when Florida Senator
Marco Rubio flippantly dismissed
the most recent COVID surge,
which is setting new records
for daily case numbers
and fueling rising
hospital admissions.
On New Year's Eve,
Rubio tweeted, "Record numbers
testing positive
for a sore throat
isn't a crisis,
and people in the hospital
for car accidents
testing positive isn't surge.
The real crisis
is the irrational hysteria,
which has people
with no symptoms
waiting hours for a test
or missing work for 10 days."
Irrational hysteria?
Anderson hold me back!
First of all,
you haunted ventriloquist dummy,
It's only a sore throat,
that's likely
because you're boosted
or at the very least,
double vaccinated,
which would be a far better
message for you to be pushing,
especially since you got
your shot before most Americans
even had access to the vaccine.
Do you remember that,
or did you block it out
because you were, you know,
being so hysterical?
Also, you think missing work
for 10 days is the real crisis
instead of letting people
stay home
to take care of themselves
and slow the spread?
That's pretty rich
coming from a senator
who once had one of the worst
attendance records in Congress.
And it's the true fact.
One of the few true facts
I learned,
from of all people,
Donald Trump who brought it up
in a GOP primary debate
amid a chorus of boos.
-This guy number one --
the number one absentee record
in the United States.
He doesn't show up to vote.
-Just a reminder, the guy
getting booed became president,
and those were Republicans
booing him.
Also, you know it's bad
when Donald Trump of all people
slams you
for not working enough.
The guy spends most of his time
wandering around his Palm Beach
golf course like the ghost
of Haggard Vance.
By the way
that clip is a reminder
if you ever want dirt
on any major Republican,
you can just rewatch
the 2016 debates.
Trump went through those guys
like Don Rickles
at the Copacabana.
Rubio's attendance record
was so bad,
Trump didn't even have
to lie about it.
Trump lies about everything,
even stuff that's good for him.
If he won the Nobel Prize,
he'd tell everyone
it was their best golfer,
big penis category.
Can you imagine the conversation
with his staff
when Trump found out
he didn't have
to make something up?
"I'm going to lie and say
it doesn't show up to vote."
"Well, it's not a lie, sir.
It's true."
"Okay, well,
then I'm going to lie
and say his real name
is Marcus Rubiokoski."
"Well, what if, sir,
and this is just a suggestion,
what if you didn't lie
at all this time?"
"No, can do.
I have to lie once
every five minutes
or my brain explodes like
the buss from 'Speed'.
'Speed,' we love 'Speed,'
don't we, folks?
A young -- a young Sandy Bullock
and a breakthrough role.
But I can't watch it anymore.
I can't watch
the film 'Speed' anymore.
It's very sad.
It's bad.
I can't watch it anymore
because it reminds me
of the 'Access Hollywood' bus
where I was treated very --
I was treated very unfairly,
very unfairly on this.
But do you guys remember that?
You barely do, don't you?
Like the whole thing
was a dream.
But it's true.
It's one of the many true
things that I did,
and everybody forgave me
and I became president."
[ Laughter ]
I hope this is a reminder
that Republicans like Rubio
pretend to be normal statesman
above the fray
are arguably just as reckless
and unhinged
as the far right weirdos
like Marjorie Taylor Greene,
who has repeatedly
lied about the vaccines
and who recently called
for a "national divorce,"
which is, I guess,
the sequel to "National Velvet."
How -- how would a national
divorce even work?
Who would get the White House?
Who would pay alimony?
Who would get custody of Eric?
It would probably just be
the two sides
pushing him back and forth.
He's a Republican,
so he should go with you.
But he's a New Yorker,
And then one critic said
it sounded like
she was calling for a civil war,
Greene defended the tweet
by writing that
"Divorces happen in court
or perhaps for a country
can happen in Congress.
Happy marriages are the result
of two committed people
working together,
resolving differences
and changing behavior
that hurts the other."
And by the way, this person
who said happy marriages
required two sides to compromise
is also the same person
who tweeted a truly depraved lie
about Democrats
and COVID last week
when she said
"The vaccines are failing
and the Democrats are tyrants.
The entire effort
should be focused
on life saving treatments
and returning life to normal.
Wide open, no mask, no mandates,
no discrimination,
and lifesaving treatments
widely available."
We all want
to get back to normal.
You are the ones
who want to live
with this endless cycle
of misery and death
and just let a highly
contagious respiratory virus
ravaged the country.
That's not normal.
The rest of us just want
to slow the spread of COVID
and get back to something
that's actually normal.
You know how badly I love
to go back to my old life
of eating indoors at restaurants
without a mask on so the waiters
would recognize my face
and comp my mail?
[ Laughter ]
They always said
the same thing.
"Oh, my God.
I loved you in 'The Office.'"
[ Laughter ]
Hey, whatever.
Whatever!
Free cheesecake
is free cheesecake.
Well, not surprisingly,
after all that,
Greene's personal account
finally got kicked off Twitter.
-Twitter is permanently
suspending the personal account
of Representative
Marjorie Taylor Greene.
According to
the social media company,
it's because Greene repeatedly
posted false information
about COVID-19.
-The Georgia Republican
just releasing a statement
bashing the social media site,
writing,
"Twitter is an enemy to America
and can't handle the truth."
-Oh, it looks like you finally
got that divorce you wanted.
And regardless of how you feel
about the ethics of
kicking politicians off Twitter,
it's just a huge quality
of life improvement.
Like when Trump
got kicked off Twitter,
trying to live in a world where
people like Trump and Greene
are constantly
screaming and saying
[bleep] Twitter is like trying
to have a conversation
with a friend on the street
next to a jackhammer.
Wow, it's great to see you!
[ Jackhammer hammering ]
I said it's great to see you!
Ma, this jackhammer!
Freaking de Blasio, am I right?!
[ Laughter ]
What? Oh, yeah, I forgot!
Freaking Adams, am I right?!
[ Hammering stops ]
People are so deeply invested
in the unhinged idea
that any attempt at all
to curb the spread of COVID
is somehow tyranny.
For example,
Congressman Madison Cawthorn
tweeted over the weekend
"Our Founding Fathers
wouldn't recognize
the America we live in today.
They would be horrified,
and rightly so."
I mean, no one
from the 1700s
would recognize anything.
I mean, Thomas Jefferson
was a renowned inventor,
but he'd still [bleep] his pants
if you showed him a Roomba.
On the other hand, if you want
to invoke the founding fathers,
George Washington famously
ordered his troops
to get inoculated
against smallpox.
And if you refused,
General Washington would
famously say...
-Sayonara, sucka.
-And yet,
despite their obsession
with prioritizing these
treatments over vaccines,
they can't even seem
to get the names right,
as Fox host Brian Kilmeade
recently demonstrated.
-Aaron Rodgers is saying
what we've been saying.
You especially, Carley,
yesterday,
where the therapeutics
of that mano --
monocolonial, uh,
the treatment --
-Monoclonal antibodies, yeah.
-Yeah, antibodies.
-Yeah, monocolonial.
You know the thing
Mr. Peanut wears.
[ Laughter ]
It's almost like they're not
monomaniacally monopolizing
the monologue
about monoclonal molecules,
and that was today's joke
for your SAT prep course,
[ Chime plays ]
Study up, kids, or don't.
It's your future.
I don't care.
Anyway, Brian, do you know
any preparation at all
before you go on TV,
or do they just pull you
out of bed,
dump cold water in your face
and throw it in front
of the camera like a hostage?
"Oh, God. Where am I?
Why are the lights so bright?"
"Just read the card, Yankee!"
"Monocolonial antibodies."
[ Laughter ]
2022 is arriving
with a fresh set of challenges,
along with the ones we were
already facing,
and the time is now to band
together in solidarity
and do something about them,
whether it's saving democracy
or keeping people healthy
and safe
from a highly contagious
respiratory virus.
We should be working together
to solve these problems.
We can do it.
To quote the song,
imagine all the people
living life in peace.
-...you!
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings over
two million meals a year
to men, women and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer
and other serious illnesses
and need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.